Salut, les mentalos ! Aujourd'hui je m'assieds parce que je vais vous raconter une histoire.
La fabuleuse histoire du baromètre de Bohr !
Et autant cette histoire est passionnante, autant j'ai des révélations à faire sur l'histoire en elle-même à la fin de la vidéo.
Un beau matin, ou un bel après-midi je n'en sais rien, Ernest Rutherford, qui était prix Nobel de chimie en 1908, reçoit un coup de fil de l'un de ses collègues.
Son collègue, qui était prof également, explique qu'il a un gros problème avec un étudiant sur une question de physique.
En fait, il a posé une question de physique à un étudiant dans un devoir, l'étudiant lui a repondu...
Et il veut lui mettre 0 pour sa réponse, alors que l'étudiant réclame, lui, qu'on lui mette un 20.
Du coup, le professeur en question et l'étudiant se sont mis d'accord pour faire appel à un arbitre impartial qui pourrait déterminer qui a raison ou qui a tort.
La question du devoir de physique qui pose problème était : montrer comment à l'aide d'un baromètre on pouvait calculer la taille d'un immeuble.
Et l'étudiant avait répondu cette réponse très maligne:
On prend le baromètre, on l'attache à une corde, on monte en haut de l'immeuble, on laisse tomber le baromètre jusqu'en bas de l'immeuble
on marque la corde, on remonte la corde, on mesure la corde au fur et à mesure qu'on la remonte et à la fin on a la taille de l'immeuble, la taille de la corde, plus la taille du baromètre.
Donc en soit, l'étudiant en question avait raison.
Puisqu'il répondait concrètement et pleinement à la question qui lui avait été posée et il donnait une réponse, une solution.
Mais le problème c'est que ce n'était pas la solution qui était attendue
et on pouvait pas lui donnait ses examens de physique en utilisant cette réponse là, qui était plus une réponse de logique.
Rutherford à ce moment-là, veut laisser une chance à l'étudiant en question et lui dit :
"Est ce que vous pouvez me trouvez une solution
pour calculer la taille de l'immeuble, une vraie solution ?"
Et là, l'étudiant en question, sort une dizaine de solutions différentes mais qui sont toutes du même acabit.
Comme par exemple, on met le baromètre au-dessus du toit, on le laisse tomber, et on chronomètre son temps de chute,
et après on utilise la formule : x = (Gt²)/2, pour trouver la distance, donc la taille de l'immeuble.
Il trouve d'autres solutions comme ça, avec la position du soleil, avec le poids du baromètre, avec la taille du baromètre...
Si en montant l'escalier à chaque fois on met une trace sur le mur pour avoir le nombre de fois où on a dupliquer la taille du baromètre.
Faire osciller comme ça le baromètre en haut de l'immeuble,
et calculer en fonction des oscillations la taille de l'immeuble par rapport à la longueur de la corde.
Et même une superbe solution qui est d'aller dans l'immeuble, au sous-sol, rencontrer le gardien et lui dire :
"Vous voyez j'ai un beau baromètre là, et bien je vous le donne si vous me donnez la taille de l'immeuble".
Et c'est à ce moment que Rutherford lui demande s'il sait la réponse qu'on attend de lui,
quelle est la "bonne réponse" entre guillemets, en tous cas la réponse attendue à cette question.
Et là l'élève en question répond :
"Oui, oui oui je sais exactement ce que vous voulez par rapport à la pression du baromètre
et je connais la formule évidemment, mais j'en ai juste marre qu'on m'explique comment je dois penser !"
Puisque évidemment la réponse c'était de calculer la pression atmosphérique au bas de l'immeuble, celle en haut de l'immeuble,
et d'en déduire du coup la taille de l'immeuble par rapport à la différence de pression atmosphérique.
Cette histoire elle est vraiment drôle et passionnante parce qu'elle met en scène deux personnes.
L'étudiant en question est censé être Bohr, Niel Bohr, qui a reçu le prix Nobel de physique en 1922.
Et donc l'arbitre en question, celui qui raconte en fait cette histoire, comme je vous l'ai dit c'était Rutherford.
Je trouve qu'elle fait partie de ces histoires qui nous ouvre aussi l'esprit pour se dire :
"Ok c'est pas parce que l'on attend ce chemin là de moi que je dois l'emprunter, toutes les solutions aussi
peuvent être potentiellements bonnes et peuvent m'être personnelles".
En clair, il n'y a pas qu'une seule façon de penser pour résoudre des problèmes
Un petit peu comme la vidéo sur la créativité que je  vous ai faite hier.
Mais j'ai fait quelques recherches pour avoir les sources quand même de tout cet évènement.
Et il s'avère que c'est une légende urbaine.
Ca n'a pas eu lieu, en tout cas pas entre Ruther Ford et Bohr.
Parce que la première fois que Ruther Ford et Bohr se sont rencontrés, c'était en 1912.
Et en 1912, Bohr n'était déjà plus étudiant depuis quelques années.
Ils s'étaient rencontrés pour travailler justement sur les projets scientifiques, donc ça ne pouvait pas être une histoire vraie.
Quand on creuse et qu'on cherche encore plus, on se rend compte malheureusement que c'est une histoire fictive.
Elle a été écrite dans un journal, dont je vous mets le nom juste ici.
En 1958.
Et au fur et à mesure, on lui a attribué deux noms, à savoir le nom de Bohr pour l'étudiant et le nom de Ruther Ford pour l'arbitre.
Quand j'ai eu connaissance de cette histoire il y a quelques années, je pensais que c'était une histoire vraie parce qu'on me l'avais raconté comme étant une histoire vraie.
Et je la trouvais assez intéressante en soi.
Et après en cherchant j'ai eu une légère déception.
Et cette déception elle était gommé, parce que peu importe que ce ne soit pas attribué réellement à Bohr ou à Ruther Ford, peu importe que ce ne soit pas arrivé.
Je trouve que le message que donne l'histoire est plus important que le fait qu'elle a été réelle ou non.
Ainsi s'achève cette vidéo hors sujet.
Hors sujet, mais pas que. De la playlist "Hors sujet mais pas que..."
J'espère que ça vous aura intéressé, et peut-être que vous aurez découvert cette histoire comme ça.
Demain ce sera aussi une vidéo un petit peu différente.
Je referai un Vlog demain, ça fait très longtemps que je n'en n'ai pas fait.
Là j'étais au festival "face et si", il y a une petit semaine de ça.
J'avais fait pleins d'images, donc que je vous mets un Vlog.
Avant je faisais un Vlog par semaine, maintenant j'en fais un petit peu moins...
De temps en temps... Je sais que ce n'est pas forcément ce qui est le plus regardé sur la chaine mais ça me tient à cœur de continuer à en faire.
Ça s'appelle quand même le "Mental Vlog" tout ça !
Si cette histoire et cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine avant de partir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[musique]
Je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre à la Garennes-Colombe. C'est la date la plus proche de Paris, si jamais vous voulez venir. Sinon il y a toutes les dates de tournée sur mon site !